we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors nebia is a revolutionary shower
head that saves you money by using 45
percent less water but with a stream of
water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman
hydrant is the delicious fruit drink
powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration and it's more
cost
effective than expensive sugary sports
drinks to get 25
off go to drink hydrant dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com slash david
pakman so we have to start today digging
further into the supposed covid relief
bill
a so-called rescue package for
i guess it's supposed to be for
americans even though
it's really apparently for corporations
and rich people and this has now been
approved by congress and this may be one
of the biggest scams of 2020 and there
have been many scams in 2020 the trump
campaign was a scam
trump's handling of covid was a massive
scam and failure
trump's continued claims of things like
it's the flu 15 cases will go to zero
that's a massive scam
trump's campaign fundraising to launder
money through a shell company to his
family it's a scam trump fundraising
after the election
claiming the money will help him
overturn the results when it's really
going
50 to help him pay off his campaign debt
it's scam after scam this is the year of
scams
but this cobit rescue package is a major
scam now as i told you yesterday it's a
900 billion dollar total package
it's part of a bigger package that
includes 1.4 trillion for funding
government
so you wrap a bunch of stuff not related
to covid
into the relief bill and then connect it
to the spending bill it's not super
clear why but that's not necessarily a
problem
but then you see the details for people
not corporations just normal people
making up to 75 000
a year they get six hundred dollars per
adult
you get an extra three hundred dollars
per week of unemployment
if you are out of a job altogether and
on state unemployment for 11 months
money might start going out as soon as
next week maybe
last time it took months and months so
we'll see
but the real story here is the pathetic
nature
of of how money for people compares
to money for everything else including
corporations after remember
seven months of nothing being done
so let's go through it i mentioned that
combining the 1.4 trillion dollar bill
to fund government with the 900 billion
covid relief is not necessarily a
problem and it's not necessarily a
problem except here
it is a problem because in total the two
things together
are more than 5 500 pages and the vote
took place last night
just a few hours after the full text was
released again
ensuring that no member of congress
could actually see what they were voting
for
this is a common scam in our government
it happens all the time and one of the
things that was stuck into the bill
is that it would make it illegal it
would make it a felony
to illegally stream video as an example
as well as a bunch of other
pro-corporate handouts in terms of
intellectual property
and congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez pointed this out
and explained this is an example of what
they didn't have time to read
tweeting quote this is why congress
needs time to actually read this package
before voting on it
members of congress have not read this
bill it's over 5000 pages
arrived at 2pm today and we are told to
expect a vote in two hours this isn't
governance
it's hostage taking and she's correct
the bill has a handout of 120 billion
to rich business owners and other
provisions that are great for the
wealthy
there's a provision that businesses that
get ppp loans
can not only have the loans for given
meaning it's free money
but they can also deduct the loan amount
spent on business expenses against their
taxable income so
you get a million dollar ppp loan as an
example you don't have to pay it back so
it's really a gift of a million dollars
but then also the stuff you spend the
money on from the loan which was free
you deduct from your taxes and it lowers
your taxable income i mean it's truly
wild and meanwhile
some people will get six hundred dollars
now
uh uh i i there's this other provision
about
increasing the deductibility of meals
from 50
to 100 some people are mad about this as
well
i've dealt with this before like if i go
to a conference for a week and i spend a
few hundred dollars on meals during the
conference or
i take the team out for dinner if you
can imagine that i mean
you know it's covered but at the time
when we did if i spend 100 bucks on
meals for the team
i can only deduct 50 of it only 50 of it
essentially is a tax-deductible expense
they want to up that to 100 they have up
that to a hundred percent
i like it and then it benefits me this
is the only thing
that i get and this is an opportunity
for me to to mention again
people keep emailing me saying david you
greedy bastard
you want more money for yourself you
want twelve hundred dollars instead of
six hundred
again i'm getting nothing i qualify for
nothing
i would benefit from the hundred percent
deductibility of meals as a business
expense if there's ever a thing as a
business meal again okay
but i'm we've taken no ppp money uh i
get no money personally
i have no kids that they get money i i
get nothing okay i'm thinking about
other people
um so this is way bigger than any one
thing is the point and
part of this is that lots of democrats
are fine with all this stuff just like
republicans
some are not like aoc but she still
voted for it because
600 is better than nothing and she was
given two hours to read
5500 pages part of this is that
there simply isn't even time to know
what's in the bill as i mentioned
and then part of this is that at a
systemic level
how do you go seven months with nothing
and then offer six hundred dollars
while giving huge corporations tons of
goodies and handouts it's quite frankly
infuriating
this is what we have now let's see what
happens
after january 20th with a different
president
and we don't yet know maybe a different
party controlling the senate and again
those georgia races are very much in
focus
this is absolutely fascinating and
infuriating and i want to be super
careful here to ensure that i'm not
violating any guidelines on any of our
platforms
we finally found one example
of what the right has been calling dead
people voting and of course
it wasn't a dead person it was a live
person doing something
illegal a pro-trump pennsylvania man
has been charged with voter fraud for
casting a ballot for donald trump
under his dead mother's name i'm going
to get into the details in a moment but
remember
the voter fraud trumpist crowd for seven
weeks now has been saying
hundreds of thousands of dead people
voted for joe biden in the 2020 election
in some cases they say tens of thousands
when this was investigated it turned out
that it happened
essentially not at all most of the
people listed as dead
in i believe it was in michigan were
just alive
i mean that that that's really they were
people who did vote
but they're alive they're not dead
others were
registered they died since registering
and they didn't vote so in other words
they showed up as registered because
they were but they died and didn't vote
because dead people can't vote
uh some others were name confusion a
junior
voting and then it being counted uh as
their dad's vote
senior who has passed away but it was
still only one vote counted it wasn't it
being counted twice for one person it's
a clerical error
and of course the implication always was
that this was part of a scam to help joe
biden steal the election
another claim they didn't have any
evidence for aside from the fact that
it's really a bad strategy to steal an
election it's so much work for one vote
in this way
but we finally found out that somebody
did do this
and it is a 70 year old man named bruce
bartman in pennsylvania
who registered his dead mother and his
dead mother-in-law to vote
using the online registration portal
registered them both as republicans
requested absentee ballots in their
names and returned one of the absentee
ballots for his deceased mother
voting for trump he's confessed he made
a statement to the da's office saying
he cast a vote for his in the name of
his dead mother
for donald trump and there are many
takeaways here
first of all the claim from the trump is
that this is widespread
is a fantasy pennsylvania received
hundreds of
tips about supposed dead voters they
followed up on all of them
and they found one and it the guy voted
for trump okay
number two the story from the right is
always that
it's democrats doing the voter fraud and
yet every time it's investigated every
election
it's a handful of republicans doing it
there was a similar story
back in 2016 maybe 2018 maybe both
there were scary generalizations about
voter fraud but when we found the few
instances of people doing it earnestly
uh it was republicans we found instances
of republicans
testing the system trying to vote twice
and they got caught
and once again here 70-year-old
republican
caught submitting a ballot for trump in
the name of his dead mother
one other republican in pennsylvania was
also charged
for casting a ballot in person went home
put on sunglasses went back to the
polling place and claimed to be his own
son to vote a second time he's also been
caught and charged
so again no evidence of materially
relevant voter fraud but these two guys
accused of individual fraud which of
course would not have affected the
pennsylvania results either way
joe biden won by 71 000 votes
but the two instances were people voting
for trump anyway
so it only took seven weeks but we
finally found
one supposed dead voter and it was a
trump vote
anyway so do not fall for this stuff my
friends
it really will rot your brain we have
real problems to deal with in this
country
we have real election problems and they
include suppression
closing of polling places
disenfranchisement of different kinds we
have a long list
quote dead people voting not a problem
one guy did it he got caught in
pennsylvania
remember that on january 1 we are
blowing out memberships before joe biden
comes into office and says david
70 membership discounts are no longer
allowed
that's a joke by the way but we really
are doing a one-day membership special
january 1st 2021 if you would like to be
notified
about it this is very simple you go to
davidpakman.com
upper right of the website you type in
your email address puts you on our
newsletter
january 1st you'll get an email telling
you how to sign up
taking advantage of this great
membership special let me know what you
think
about the voter fraud story from
pennsylvania
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use the code pacman will get
15 off site-wide
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
if you've been wondering whether anybody
is president of the united states right
now you're not alone
donald trump hasn't had a public event
in a long time if you look at donald
trump's official schedule you'll see no
public events dating back for weeks
trump occasionally meeting with mike
pencer officials or signing something in
private
but he's been missing and yesterday this
right-wing college organization
called turning point usa did an
in-person super spreader event with the
likes
of such right-wing tours of intellectual
forces dave rubin eric
balling and three female republican
congresswomen
and uh donald trump called into the
event through the organizer charlie
kirk's
cell phone or a cell phone handed to
charlie kirk and
it is absolutely bizarre so let's look
at the clips first and then i'll talk a
little bit about just the the
downfall of the office of the presidency
over the last few months
and years uh they seem to have staged
some kind of interruption
while charlie kirk was speaking uh some
kind of flunky comes out holding a cell
phone for charlie kirk and
and has to interrupt charlie because
it's so important
if you are allergic to cringe i would
skip the next 40 seconds
i cringed really hard when i saw this
i'm so sorry i know you're in the middle
of speech
this can't wait i would never do this to
you
but this is something that we cannot
miss
hello who's there hi charlie how are you
that sounds like a big crowd of
beautiful people
[Applause]
what a surprise guys it's trump
anyway um let's listen to what trump
actually said and remember trump has
been doing
nothing for weeks other than figuring
out
ideas for how to steal the election but
this event he calls into take a listen
and of course trump starts talking about
how he needs the justice department to
do something
to steal the election that he lost and
again asserts that he won the election a
quick reminder donald trump
did not win the election
that sounds like a big crowd of
beautiful people
mr president
we have 4 000 students here it's amazing
to hear from you
and our student action summit and thank
i
thank you for calling in i mean we have
your back a hundred percent by the way
100 i know you do i know you do
i know charlie i appreciate it i
appreciate everybody
there i've spoken for charlie numerous
times and we've always had a great time
and
we are fighting uh really for the
country because
this election we won this election in a
landslide
they dropped hundreds of thousands of
ballots at each state
it's all documented the problem is we
need a party that's gonna fight and we
have some great congressmen and women
that are doing it
and we have others some great fighters
but we won this in a landslide they know
it
and we need backing from like the
justice department and other people have
to finally step
up but i just want to thank charlie for
the support charlie's always been there
i watched you the other night
we won by a lot he says uh of course not
true
and this is really a crowd that will
cheer for anything truly
imagine thinking that you're building uh
a solid fact-based
organization that is willing to cheer
wildly
when trump lies and claims he won an
election that he obviously lost
significantly now just one other little
moment that shows you
really just how dumb these right-wing
figures
think the crowd is this is not about
this is more a commentary about the
organizers
and the speakers than it is about the
audience
charlie kirk casually mentions trump
took time out of his busy day
negotiating the stimulus to talk to this
crowd
look this is why we love our president
he's in he's in washington dc
negotiating the stimulus bill
and but he wanted to make sure that he
talked to you most people would realize
that that's completely patronizing and
ridiculous especially the idea that
trump is negotiating anything that's
laughable
but sadly this type of stuff really
works on people because the mag occult
is is very it's just bizarre
and when i was watching these these
clips
it brought back memories of
documentaries i've seen about
evangelical christian youth
conferences where they indoctrinate kids
into evangelical christianity sometimes
it's specifically
sects that fall under the umbrella of
charismatic christian churches these are
the ones that sometimes speak in tongues
sometimes it's pentecostal anyway
there's lots of interesting
documentaries about these types of
churches
uh jesus camp is one in which our our
good friend mike pap antonio actually
um uh plays a role but that's what i was
reminded of as i was watching these
videos it they they seem
like these evangelical indoctrination
camps that people that kids are sent to
these are just slightly older kids
effectively is what's going on
really sad stuff and again trump missing
for weeks from the public
this he calls into unbelievable we had
part one of this next story yesterday
and now it's actually gotten even more
interesting
uh right wing propaganda network newsmax
has now been forced to debunk its own
election lies due to a legal threat from
the voting machine company smartmatic
which
both demanded a retraction and reserved
its right to take legal action
yesterday i told you that after six
weeks of spreading all sorts of debunked
lies about election fraud
lou dobbs on fox aired a clarifying
segment
saying basically none of that stuff i
said was true newsmax has now done the
exact same thing so let's take a look at
uh this is anchor john tobacco that's
his real name as far as i know
issuing clarifications and the title of
this clip should really be we don't want
to get sued
since election day various guests
attorneys and elected officials have
appeared on newsmax and offered opinions
and claims about smartmatic
and dominion systems both companies that
offer voting software in the u.s
and newsmax would like to clarify its
news coverage and note
that it has not reported as true certain
claims made about these companies
there are several facts our viewers and
readers should be aware of
newsmax has found no evidence that
either dominion or smartmatic owns the
other
or has any business association with
each other
we have no evidence that dominion uses
smartmatic software or vice versa
no evidence has been offered that
dominion or smartmatic used software
or reprogrammed software that
manipulated votes in the 2020 election
smartmatic has stated that its software
was only used in the 2020 election in
los angeles
was not used in any battleground state
contested by the trump campaign
newsmax has no evidence to the contrary
dominion has stated the company has no
ownership relationship with the pelosi
family the feinstein family
the clinton family hugo chavez or the
government of venezuela
neither dominion nor smartmatic has any
relationship with george soros
smartmatic is a u.s company and not
owned by the venezuelan government
hugo chavez or any foreign official or
entity
smartmatic states that it has no
operations in venezuela
while the company did election projects
in venezuela from 2004
to 2017 it states it was never founded
by hugo chavez nor did it have a corrupt
relationship with him
or the venezuelan government for more on
this please go to our website at
newsmax.com
if that isn't a guy being held hostage
by the company's lawyers i don't know
what is
so just like with yesterday's fox clip
the newsmax anchor says there's no
connection between smartmatic and
dominion
votes weren't manipulated by the voting
machines
the machines in question weren't used in
battleground states there's no
connection to nancy pelosi or hugo
chavez or the clintons or venezuela
george soros has nothing to do with this
and it's really quite stunning
and just like i said yesterday lots of
the news max
audience will hear this but they're not
going to believe it because they will
believe
that the newsmax host was forced to do
this which he was
essentially because of the legal demand
letter that was received but i'll
actually even go further
how do you make up for five weeks of
spreading disinformation
seven weeks almost at this point
hundreds of times
with this one segment this is the lu dog
segment similar to uh what we just saw
on newsmax this was
yesterday on fox business take a look
lots of opinions about the
integrity of the election the
irregularities of mail-in
voting of election voting machines and
voting software
one of the companies is smartmatic and
we reached out to one of the leading
authorities on open source software for
elections
eddie perez for his insight and views
eddie is the global director of tech
development at the open source
election technology institute we asked
him for his assessment of smartmatic
and recent claims about the company
have you seen any evidence that
smartmatic software was used to flip
votes anywhere in the us in this
election
i have not seen any evidence that
smartmatic software was used to
delete change alter
anything related to vote tabulation
smartmatic says its software was never
used outside of la county in 2020
do you know whether or not that's true
that is my understanding smartmatic
uh functioned as the contract
manufacturer
for the los angeles county voting system
and that was a customized system that
was effectively built to the county's
order
i am not aware of them having any other
direct customers relationships with
election officials in the united states
what about smartmatic and dominion do
you know if they're related
whether one owns the other whether
dominion uses smartmatic software
both dominion and smartmatic have
individually and respectively put out
very clear statements from their
corporate headquarters
each of them indicating they are
independent companies they are not
related to each other
it is my understanding that neither one
of them has an ownership stake in the
other
or anything like that so almost
identical information is being conveyed
in the two videos
clearly they don't want to face the
lawsuits that they were being threatened
with
but i just don't know how one two minute
fact check
once makes up for spreading this stuff
for going on two months
but of course they're doing the absolute
minimum
to either avoid being sued or to
mitigate damage if indeed they are sued
that's all they care about now here's a
bonus clip for you this is this is great
uh host sebastian gorka
is interviewing the my pillow guy mike
lindell
and mike lindell starts going into the
voter fraud
conspiracies and seb gorka actually cuts
him off
because he clearly has been advised we
can't keep repeating this stuff take a
look
i believe in this president but and i'll
tell you what
nobody realized this i mean what a
miracle we had on election night
at 11 15 you know you talked about all
this fraud
doctor the the the biggest broad is the
dominion machines
and at 11 15 on election night
our great president because i don't want
to discuss
mike mike we're not we're not going to
get into the minutiae of the details
i want to ask you because this show is
about courage
so seb gorka they're desperate to get
away from that topic before they end up
with another
legal threat so the headlines go on the
front
every day for six weeks and then they
put a correction on the back page
once that's the equivalent of what
they're doing here
fox news was told in the letter from the
smartmatic lawyers
you need to claim there wasn't fraud
with the same amount of frequency and
intensity as the number of times you
claimed there was fraud
clearly fox news hasn't done that
clearly newsmax hasn't done that for now
but my concern is less legal
than it is about the reality that the
damage has been done
by their harping on this stuff for six
weeks they may get sued anyway because
their lives were so egregious
but the problem is that when you do this
for six or seven weeks
the correction is irrelevant you're not
going to change any of your own
audience's mind because they understand
that you were clearly forced to do this
and that what you said for six weeks is
the truth as they see it will oan have
to do the same i don't know we're
keeping an eye on that
but this is already a sign that as i've
been saying for several weeks now
the right-wing media landscape for the
next several years
is going to be very interesting
regardless of what donald trump does
uh and we'll be following it and we'll
have more of these clips on the david
pakman show instagram page which you can
find
at david pakman show the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water
for rehydration and they're giving you
25
off your first order it's made with four
key
electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great it's made with real
fruit juice it's been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
today i'm going to be speaking with
robert vitalis who is professor of
political science at the university of
pennsylvania and also
author of the book oil craft the myths
of scarcity and security
that haunt u.s energy policy um so great
to have you on i i think at the time of
a presidential transition where
there are questions about if and how
policy will change around oil it's
it's a very timely conversation thanks
it's great to be here
so i i guess to start with when you talk
about
oil craft or or the trick that is
sometimes
played with the topic of oil like what
is the big trick what's the big
misunderstanding
well the big misunderstanding is that
you don't have to do
anything special to guarantee access to
it especially during peace time
meaning there's a world market in oil
one just buys it that is how the
military gets its oil that is how
all domestic refiners get their oil so
all talk about need to use military
power to secure
access or against threats um
are pretty much uh uh untrue
and can you talk a little bit about why
so there's there's probably
some people who will hear you say that
and they'll say okay well there's an
aspect of that that makes intuitive
sense but at the same time
the world wouldn't necessarily grind to
a halt if access to a different
commodity like pork bellies were somehow
impacted it seems as though because so
much transportation depends on oil
so many products uh including products
that have plastic
come from oil and so many different
things it seems that
the implications are different even if
on paper we're talking about two
commodities why do you argue that there
is not really a difference
because the the vision of um
access somehow being denied by some uh
crisis is also something that hasn't
existed in uh
in our lives so for instance right now
access is being hindered in all sorts of
way
to oil supplies but we hardly think
about it what is the perfect example of
that
uh the united states government has
sanctions on various governments
that are oil producers venezuela on the
one hand
uh iran on the other the that that
hinders access
uh in in real ways but we don't talk
about it instead
what we imagine is some kind of i don't
know like
a disaster movie where all oil
uh all oil production collapses we we've
never had an
experience like that but we we generate
constant uh
scary scenarios one of the
global relationships that uh
uses oil as a justification for being
sort of a special relationship or one
that needs to be treated differently is
the u.s
relationship with saudi arabia and
sometimes if you step back it might be
sort of confusing given
the democratic values that so many
administrations have claimed to want to
spread around the world and in fact many
of the military conflicts
based on spreading those ideas it would
seem counter-intuitive that we would
have the relationship we do with saudi
arabia
which represents much of what we seek to
change in that region and elsewhere in
the world
but oil and a shared goal of stability
in the region is often cited as
as the explanation how does your
uh perspective on oil modify how maybe
we should be thinking of that
relationship
well one that is correct oil is used
as the explanation for what we
ostensibly otherwise would not do
right so and you know basically that's
another
a scary scenario to uh that has
that have trip that has tricked people
in the past so americans who otherwise
would not think we have some kind of we
should be
uh so closely involved with saudi arabia
except
okay but we need their oil uh and and so
we have to kind of swallow our pride or
or not pursue our more idealistic side
and that's fundamentally incorrect as my
favorite oil economist of the 1970s
uh said back then and it remains true
until now
this one thing saudi arabia has to do is
sell their oil on the world market the
one thing we
don't have to worry about is access to
oil from saudi arabia or anyone else has
has to worry about are there other um
relationships so you you mentioned
venezuela we know about the the
relationship with saudi arabia
are there other geopolitical alliances
or relationships
that that are important when it comes to
oil that are much less discussed in
media and that people may not understand
the the role of well i think folks you
can just think about the us position
in the persian gulf generally not just
in saudi arabia but in bahrain where the
fifth fleet is located
uh in uh qatar in the emirates and
and so forth um we have this
understanding that we have to be in the
persian gulf
to protect access to oil and what i've
argued and what the military has said
time and time again and other experts is
that that is incorrect and so the real
question should be
so what behind that behind the uh
a rationale of strategic access to oil
what do these regimes actually do for us
uh that that uh keep us so closely tied
to them
i i want to get to eventually in our
conversation some of the reasons why
we've not moved off of oil more quickly
but before addressing that um because
there are so many geopolitical
relationships that are connected to oil
there are significant it would seem
diplomatic and foreign policy
implications that would that would rise
if indeed the u.s and the world were to
accelerate getting off of oil and
towards renewable energy
and and other types of of energy sources
is that
intuition accurate in in a sense or are
or do you believe that there would
simply be
new justifications given for maintaining
the status quo which now
oil is pointed to as the explanation i i
i
you know i i'm i uh you you shouldn't
trust professors to predict anything
but of course that said i i
lean toward your second uh uh option
there
right other rationales will be created
to continue uh uh to pursue the policies
that we pursue now that whatever else
they do
have no impact on act on access to oil
we have a perfect example of this the
united states
is has a has a large military presence
in the persian gulf
in the past weeks uh saudi oil
facilities or
oil transport have been uh uh uh
bombed by ships and and the us is
unable to to prevent the precise kinds
of uh
threats that we've often think is at the
heart of our military presence there
but does the nate does the military want
to stay there absolutely
all else equal the military presence
is of benefit to the military um they've
never been really
uh behind any kind of a retreat from
positions where they are already secured
what would be the and again maybe i'm
asking for a prediction or maybe maybe
we have a reason to to think one way or
the other
if the excuse of oil were no longer
credible in terms of explaining a u.s
saudi relationship that doesn't seem to
make much
sense for the reasons we discussed
earlier what do you imagine would
replace it as the justification
well well whether it would work or not
okay whether americans would come to say
okay yes we have to do we
we have to accept uh our ties to the
saudis we have no other choice
well one is a new one this is the one
credit i give to mohammed bin salman the
de facto ruler
um
it's a plus on the side of israel and
those americans who really think
it's important that the saudis are part
of a coalition
with israel against iran right and you
notice in that discussion there's no
talk about oil the oil disappears
right and in fact we'd be better off uh
if iran was producing
its oil uh unhindered by the united
states it's of course
it's of course producing oil but it's
doing that with the assistance of china
at this point okay so when we think
about why we've not moved away from oil
more quickly we seem to have the
technological know-how to do it to a
greater degree than it has
has been done and there are all sorts of
explanations that are often given some
are more foreign policy related uh
including what you and i have been
talking about some claim that we simply
don't have the efficiency in some of
these alternatives to oil to generate
the energy we need
that while solar panels are improving
and wind is improving
we're simply not there yet and there's a
debate about that and it seems that
it to great extent it's not true it's
part about political willingness to do
it but but maybe to some degree we're
not quite there
there are other explanations given as
well in terms of will it would damage
this industry
well but it would prop this one up and
then you have to kind of balance whether
it would be a net job creator or or
destroyer
if you had to give us a general
assessment of why we've not moved away
from oil more quickly
what would it include uh political will
i think um uh
the obfuscating arguments of multiple
you know uh vested interests in this
process
you know i've watched this i i've
studied how these debates
took place in the 1970s during the
so-called energy crisis
and there was a lot of confusion out
there because
um spokespeople of different interests
tend to argue
uh uh their positions uh they tend to
exaggerate
you know the the significance or the or
the
or the importance or the security
threats to their various positions
so i think lack of political will yes
the technology is not completely there
yet but at the same time i've noticed
something uh
uh happening for the first time which is
um the oil industry itself or at least
the largest segments of the oil industry
the global
the global producers are arguing in fact
they are preparing for a
peak not supply which is how we used to
talk about it but peak demand
that in fact their predictions are oil
demand for oil will be declining over
you know the medium term etc so i think
something is happening
and what do they say would be the the
catalyst for those declines in demand
uh concerns about global warming uh
the environment and the uh uh
commit commitments on par i mean the
commitments of
various uh domestic groups to the fears
of what climate change mean
plus the tech plus the developments in
the technology
um you know that's what economists have
said at some point oil will
oil will simply become a wasted asset
that will remain in the ground because
technology will shift such that
um we can we we will have a better
energy source sources to rely on so
along those lines the the president uh
trump the the one that's still president
for a few more days
um he has said many times during his
rallies and during
various briefings even briefings
unrelated to energy as they often are
he has uttered this this phrase that we
are now energy independent
um first question is is that true
and then a second question is has
fracking impacted the us
energy picture in a significant enough
way
that it has separated us a little bit
from the geopolitical oil situation
okay uh great questions uh no we are not
energy independent because we live in a
world
it's one world market for oil all right
we believe you you know we have this
fiction we think that
domestic sources of supply is what the
country first relies on and then
and only then does it does it uh a turn
to exports that has never been true
number one number two even to the extent
that we are now producing more oil
through a hydraulic fracturing
than we had in the then then we've had
for a long time
the price of that oil depends on
uh events in the world market so there
is no way to stop
the what drives us most crazy in the
day-to-day
the um uh uh volatility and prices of
oil
right so now we're all
prices are down but we remember back
when barrels of oil were at 102
right well in the future we are not able
to uh uh
uh put up walls against those
price shocks unless we turn to a kind of
uh domestic politics that we haven't
seen in this country for decades
which was which would be to create a new
protectionist regime right
not permit any uh uh not permit any
imports of oil
and rely completely on domestic
production
well that you know that's been a failure
in the past that's caused
all sorts of problems uh in the united
states and it's hard to imagine
returning to that now has frat has
fracking
uh reduced our dependency and no
because i i i it's just not the case so
there's one there's an easy way to see
that we can look at our oil
import uh uh figures and um
they're our we still import oil right
because certain users
um prefer the uh their own refineries
are geared towards certain kinds of oil
and it's very difficult for them to
move away from the oil that they tend to
use let me give you
one good example that people never think
of yeah
folks argued they expected that with uh
hydraulic fracturing
um we would not any longer be dependent
on saudi arabia and
import from saudi arabia would decline
well that's not true
why people forget that saudi arabia is
itself
a major refiner in the united states the
largest amount of saudi oil coming to
the united states is to
is to uh uh supply their own refineries
in the united states in the same way
that a global oil company like exxon
would do so setting up refineries in
various countries
in order to have guaranteed markets for
their crude etc
so saudi arabia continues to import
saudi arabian oil into saudi refineries
in the united states uh real quick the
last thing i wanted to touch on
and and my my expectation is your
commentary on this would be more
geopolitical than technological but i'm
glad to hear your thoughts either way
there are folks on the left who are
sometimes divided over the role of
new nuclear capacity and technology uh
in it as a possible bridge from the
current paradigm
to renewables and there are some who
don't like the the sort of um risk of
nuclear
while the more nuclear engineers i talk
to the more they
say you know that those risks are really
based on 40 50 year old technology
which is not what would be used if new
nuclear was put online so i'm sort of
open to the idea
of new nuclear as a bridge my concern is
that practically because it takes a
while to bring that capacity on
it seems it would be difficult to commit
to it merely being a bridge
what is your sort of thought about new
nuclear as as
and its role well i think i your your
vision of that is is is mine it's i
think is
is the correct one um and also the
what doesn't often get talked about is
the fact that
those new nuclear plants would be
subsidized by the
by government in one form or another
right it's very hard to do it
economically now without subsidies so
you can imagine
another new you know industry uh seeking
pursue you know
seeking those subsidies in order to in
order to
uh uh get new plants uh uh
uh operational um you know
the text i read on this question the
debate is still open i've seen
i've seen books you know by actually old
friends of mine from graduate school
who've argued this is
this is the only real way forward
especially if what we care about
is generating electricity for the
millions of people in india and
elsewhere that still
have no electricity renewables are not
going to be able to
to uh uh uh and uh give the development
uh that folks need around the world and
nuclear is the way to do that but i've
also seen
technologists challenge challenge that
claim so
i think what we're going to see is i
mean i i can't resolve that
right what we're going to see is more
fights around that question and it's
certainly
there is certainly a uh visceral
uh argument against it on the part of
the left and i think that goes back to
you know back to the 70s to uh chernobyl
to three mile island uh and so forth to
no
nukes there was there were the concerts
back then right and the left is
i'm i'm with you on this the left seems
more or less committed to the idea of
green new deal renewables uh uh
supporting fossil fuels or any other
kind of mega industry
at the same time yep uh i uh an issue of
critical importance and one maybe to
expand on uh
in in the future we've been speaking
with robert vitalis who's a professor of
political science at the university of
pennsylvania
also author of the book oil craft the
myths of scarcity and security
that haunt u.s energy policy thanks so
much for your time today
and take good care the david pakman show
at david davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist make sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
these next clips are an absolute
pleasure to watch uh donald trump's
kooky lawyer rudy giuliani has turned on
donald trump's kooky lawyer sydney
powell
now there are about four or five layers
of hilarity here the first layer of
hilarity is that weeks ago
when sydney powell appeared to go crazy
at these events at which she appeared
with rudy giuliani claiming hugo chavez
and venezuela cuba
and tifa were all involved in stealing
the election oh george soros too
trump put out a statement saying this
woman has no involvement with this
period she's
working by herself then rudy giuliani
went
justice bonkers himself telling us about
as crazy of a story about what happened
with the election
then trump had sidney powell at the oval
office on friday
and she was the one pushing trump to do
absolutely ridiculous things like
trying to forcibly seize voting machines
and then the latest just incredible uh
event in this series of of embarrassment
is that rudy giuliani appeared yesterday
on sean spicer's news max program
and appeared to turn on sydney powell
now before we even get to that
sean spicer's newsmax program yes
sean spicer donald trump's former white
house press secretary
has a show on newsmax that alone is
hilarious but i can't even focus on that
because we have to get to what rudy says
here is rudy insinuating that sydney
powell's approach
is outside of rationality common sense
and the law take a look
right and i know some of these folks
have picked her up going in and out of
the
the west wing but is she to the best of
your knowledge
meeting with the president about some of
these strategic moves to either
impound or seize voting machines or
become a special counsel to investigate
fraud well look it's my responsibility
as the president's lawyer along with
jenna and some of the others
we're going to be extremely aggressive
we're going to fight for our client as
hard as we can
but we're also going to do it within the
bounds of rationality common sense
and the law and it can be done
there's no reason to go beyond anything
that there was this election was a theft
it can be proven i can tell you one
simple thing that would prove it
make the american people feel really
good five or six of these
crooked governors could let us have
access
to the machines what's really just
kafka-esque here
is that rudy giuliani is no voice of
reason rudy giuliani is pursuing ideas
that are almost as nutty as what he's
saying
sydney powell is going too far with but
he says
she's going too far and she's not
working with us well rudy you're doing
things that are essentially as bonkers
as what she's doing
uh here is rudy in plain english saying
sydney powell is on her own
rudy by the way appears to be doing the
interview from a restaurant it sounds
like there's silverware clanking in the
background
but i want to bring you back to these
reports that in the oval office
sidney powell who had been part of your
legal team until she was dismissed
has been there at least three
potentially four times so
there's a rumor that she is trying to
become or
people are advocating that she'd be
appointed special counsel and that their
voting machines be seen can you tell us
what's happening in the oval office and
what her role will be
let me say definitively cindy powell is
not part of our legal team
she hasn't been for five weeks she is
not a special counsel for the president
she does not speak for the president nor
does she speak for the administration
she speaks for herself and she's a fine
woman a fine lawyer
but whatever she is talking about it's
our own opinions i'm not responsible for
them the president isn't
nor is anybody else on our legal team so
now
rudy is both distancing himself from
sydney powell but at the same time
not and what i mean by that is he says
she's not part of the legal team well we
knew that
we knew the trump trump claimed that
weeks ago rudy says she's not special
counsel well we know that right now
she's not special counsel the story is
trump is thinking about making her
special counsel
rudy says she doesn't speak for the
president no one claimed she did she's
not his press secretary
and rudy says she doesn't speak for the
trump administration again nobody has
claimed that
so notice how rudy distances
while not actually refuting the
assertions which include
sydney powell was at the oval office on
friday sydney powell met with trump
sydney powell suggested a seizure of
voting machines and trump is thinking
about appointing her special counsel
rudy doesn't debunk any of that
he just generally distances and then
lastly and this is so funny
here's rudy on newsmax with sean spicer
now attacking fox news saying fox news
won't let him on anymore to make his
voter fraud claims
i can't get on i can't get on abc nbc
cbs i can't even get a fox anymore
if i say the word fraud i'm thrown off
the network
i'm sorry there was fraud
i'm telling the truth and they're lying
completely indistinguishable from parody
at this point
very strange times that we we live in
i'm shocked daily
that this is real life and speaking of
fox news
let's talk about what happened there i
kind of like this clip
not because fox news anchor chris
wallace is some huge critic of fox news
while being on fox news but because it's
a thinly veiled shot at some of the
nonsense that's been regurgitated by fox
news
since the election including remember
this story of right-wingers going after
dr jill biden because
she's being called doctor without being
a medical doctor so let's look at this
clip from sunday's interview
where chris wallace interviewed incoming
white house press secretary jen
sackey uh let's take a look at the clip
finally
there has been some criticism recently
from
conservatives including some
conservatives on fox news
about the fact that first lady to be
jill biden goes by
the title doctor i i wonder
what is the biden's reaction to that
especially given the fact that so
many people over the years uh i think of
dr henry kissinger the reverend dr
martin luther king have gone by the
title doctor even though they're not
medical doctors and nobody seems to have
made a fuss about that
that's exactly right chris it's a bit
perplexing to me and i'm sure to
millions of americans that
with thousands of people dying every day
of covid millions out of work
that anyone wake up in the morning and
decide that the focus they need to have
the way they contribute to society that
day
is to question whether or not dr jill
biden
someone who's still teaching who has a
phd
in education should be called a doctor
or not of course she should as anyone
who
works through that challenging process
of getting a phd it's a
it's a really silly sexist and absurd uh
conversation that's happening a bit in
society and i appreciate you asking me
about it
jen thank you thanks for your time the
criticism
from conservatives on fox news chris
wallace says now as i said on the stream
that i did yesterday we have a very
backwards situation
right now where people without any
college degrees
or people with bachelor's degrees in
areas that have nothing to do with
education
are evaluating the merits of jill
biden's doctoral thesis
her dissertation about education random
right-wing journalists with no
experience in ed policy
or in the academic field of education
are saying criticism of dr jill biden is
fair
because her dissertation was crap
there's a bigger picture here
that exists on the right and it's been
growing over the last
some odd years a flash point was when
former
republican senator rick santorum said
college is
liberal indoctrination and let me see if
i can sort of lay it out
one of the laughable things that
happened yesterday at this event
by uh turning point usa which we covered
is that an incoming republican
congresswoman defiantly said i will go
and debate any professor at any college
hold on what do you mean debate any
professor like you would debate an
astronomy professor about the planets
you'll debate a chemical engineering
professor about chemical engineering
what do you mean you'll debate any
professor and what i'm guessing she was
implying is she would debate any
professor about politics
but it's this arrogance and perspective
that's become a viru it's like a mind
virus
and it's the same sort of delusion
that's taking place with dr jill biden
this is similar to when people evaluate
the merits of dr jill biden's
dissertation without any knowledge
that would allow them to do that people
who have never been to college or people
with college degrees in an unrelated
topic
random bloggers everybody gets to
evaluate the merits
of dr jill biden's uh doctoral
dissertation
this is very common on the right the
idea that
really you just learn opinion at college
and mostly it's liberal opinion
liberal professors giving liberal
opinions
uh and then the students take the
liberal opinions and they repeat them
science is liberal they believe or infer
rather than an empirical process and
there's a dunning-kruger aspect to it
where they so misunderstand what college
is
and what empiricism is and what science
is that they don't know that there's a
difference between having an opinion
about
what the tax rate should be and
empiricism and the scientific method
that they end up lacking the capacity to
understand what is happening in college
and to even critique it in a credible
way that's how they end up thinking
it's merely liberal nonsense i can show
up and debate any professor
and i can determine whether dr jill
biden's doctoral dissertation
is meritorious or not but in any case
good for chris wallace sort of kind of
softly alluding during his interview
with white house press secretary
incoming white house press secretary
jen sackey that some of the dr joe biden
nonsense
has actually been happening on fox news
itself we have a voicemail number
that number is 219 to david p
i have a voicemail today from what could
be
one of the wackiest most uninformed
conspiracy theorists we've ever heard
from
get the children out of the room and
listen to this
hi david i'm a nurse myself i live in
florida
and my name is vivian and i'd like to
say that you
are a fool right and yes the elections
were fraud
trump won by a landslide this
was all a confiscation to
steal the election from uh from trump
biden is a crook he is corrupt
so is his family and so are a lot of
members of the democratic party they
sold us to the chinese for the most part
they don't really give a rest
but about our country okay
so i am one hundred percent agree
with trump i think that interview with
killmeade was
excellent and people like you and cnn
and msnbc
and nbc and all your stations that
everybody basically report lies
okay and they shouldn't even be called
reporters
because you're all in the pockets of
soros bill gates and people like him
all right it's disgusting what you're
doing to this country
and and the fools that listen to you
that believe you
it's really a darn shame
you should be ashamed of yourself for
calling yourself an american
people like you shouldn't even live in
this country okay
don't change our country you've done
enough harm with your
stupid ass lines so this is this is
essentially
the this is proof that we have a
multi-generational problem in this
country
okay um that doesn't get fit you
you're not going to change that person's
opinion right essentially what you need
to do is
maybe someday they'll learn something
and maybe their kids will be slightly
more tethered to reality if we improve
circumstances and maybe their kids like
it's multi-generational in that
voicemail she says
trump won biden is a criminal biden's
family is criminal
the democrats sold us to china all news
stations
tell only lies um i'm funded by george
soros
i'm funded by bill gates it's it's a
90-second voicemail
and there's about eight different
baseless conspiracy theories
with anti-semitic undertones of course
and
you know everything else you can't fix
that by saying
hey maybe we regulate fox news or you
know what like
the the takeaway is the country is
deeply sick
and there's a lot of people that are
very very sick and
you can't fix that quickly it's sad it's
very sad but you just can't fix that
quickly
we've got a great bonus show for you
today i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get fifteen percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman hydrant is the delicious fruit
drink powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration and it's more
cost effective than expensive sugary
sports drinks
to get 25 percent off go to drink
hydrant.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman